welcome to beast gaming in this video
we're gonna be completing an ops of
course and whoever finishes it in the
least amount of time wins $10,000 you
have Chris hi
we have Carl hello and we have Chandler
hey
I will also be competing once I cross
this line a timer will start and once I
cross the line on the other side the
timer will end all right I'm going Oh
Taylor you jumped in front of him so as
you see the scores going up on the right
side every 10 points is a second we
gotta get him I finished in sixteen
point seven seconds and whoever has the
lowest time at the end of all these
courses wins $10,000 or what would you
buy with that money a car still wait it
didn't win the other 10 grand Carl no if
you don't remember who won that boy
my turn I gotta get in my sonic hedgehog
mode okay penguins can fly
I don't think penguins can fly oh yeah
hold on hold on
nah come on I'm counting on you whoo no
whoo
Chandler finished in 20 2.9 seconds all
right Carl I'm gonna win this for you
because I don't want any more cars to go
through the terrible fate that your car
right now that's going through it I want
you guys to know I was driving to the
studio today and I was like gosh I love
the gaming channel this is awesome get
my aims sentence hey my boys aim up oh
don't hit me why you aim up big boom
[ __ ] watch off the line yes sir Chris
got 15 point five seconds Wow
let's put Carl in last go for it Carl
don't worry Carl if I steal money from
you again I'll give you some money to
buy a skateboard thank you
oh I got him yeah if you hit him off
here he's done Oh Carl Carl was one
fifth of a second behind Chris Chris and
Sharon first you go first
all right you guys ready let's go all
right here we go Oh a lot of arrows
already oh oh oh oh yeah give me that
give it a boy oh oh safe whoa merica
flags guarding you pink for my baby boy
my baby boy okay that one's way harder
I'll go next cuz I'm not a baby if you
knock somebody off that they are done
they are done are they oh I hit him on
it he caught the ladder baby no you guys
didn't even have to sabotage me I
sabotage myself always going for the
ladder get him off the ladder Hey
forgive me guys for going
you're paying attention but all's fair
in Minecraft oh I was taking a sip of my
drink hang up right here back up I need
a head sir
I need a headset he's about the jump oh
my gosh how is Carl have lower time than
us fastest Hulk baby but you guys shot
me in a few places that actually sped up
my process a little bit so what you're
telling me is maybe I should stand at
the end of the course and shoot this way
all right Chandler's turn go go go go oh
no baby I'm so bad right now I can't get
a shot in going I keep saying zoink but
I didn't drink him oh I mean did I do
that bad you fell off and just kind of
walked but like did I do good still you
did good we're proud of you okay
Oh Carl speeding lets you go first yeah
you go first year one bad run and I'm in
the lead where is he in between the
mushrooms oh he fell I don't know where
to go or Oh what's going on buddy Carl
what are you doing you're blowing it
girl oh my god oh that would have been
catastrophic by the way in case you guys
were curious pink oh you're lucky that
green block was there to protect your
stupid face I'm going oh he's going he's
going for real yeah I said it I quote
I'm going I'm going oh you got saved by
the green block all right come on that
was that was just that was just rude
dude I'd nailed you oh I baked him
midair Oh give me that
what I my car oh of course what Oh had
the worst time possible here I go
oh he's going he's going he's going oh
no no no we haven't hit crystal once so
you guys decide to pegged me a hundred
times but not Chris guys what is this
crap alright ready
no I'm still a little annoyed I got no
bees that's an interesting way to go Oh
Oh daddy he's going quick Oh Oh are we
gonna let Chris take 10 grand from us
yes no but he's going gosh these shoes
he's got on
oh I knocked Alvida ow
Oh run run Carl run for it no way we're
really good there you go he's safe wait
watch Chandler's time going up brah I
didn't go I'm gonna go let's see if it
does this time I'm going you guys better
not shoot me I can't even figure out how
to get in here we can't let him get this
edge even the server does someone
Chandler it away
Oh got it Wow record breaking score due
to a bug in the server Chandler scores
way higher than ours you got bugs so the
only logical thing to do is now Chandler
and Carl have to work together it's Carl
and Chandler versus me and Chris now
this is how it's going okay so it's
Chris representing Chris and Jimmy and
me representing me and Chandler are you
good at this map yeah I can definitely
do this while you're going I'll go on
your computer and then I'll shoot them
while they're trying to shoot you yes I
don't shoot you with theirs mm-hmm you
don't shoot me with arrow sex okay that
was a that was a top secret strategy we
talked about didn't we already do this
course no Carl Carlton
or should I say Chandler didn't because
he's subbing in hello ladies and
gentlemen I'm Carl I need a car is that
what I saw what you did it perfect
actually I can't tell the difference
yeah I couldn't tell Chandler go ahead
and go wait so does that mean Carl
you're not gonna shoot I don't know
maybe I will make it I won't wait wait
oh wait what is this strategy oh my
goodness let's go all right X course
I'll hold him off Crisco uh here we go
stay away stay away I'm hurting you I'm
so far away get away from me Jimmy oh
I'm gonna die uh and done I'm still not
even at the mat I didn't do so hot that
one I fell a couple of times
ah he's gone he's gone he's gone Oh No
I'm stuck oh shoot
Oh jealous messing you up so bad car Oh
Chandler you suck
you're not gonna helping me get out of
the way car am i by myself I'm jumping
in front of them so much no you're not I
got hit 12 times oh my gosh
Oh all right Chris now your turn go
before they're ready go here we go all
right go go go cheating Chris and Jimmy
we be cheap there'd already uh go go go
wait why it's Karl's score going up oh
he's going he's going [ __ ] oh I'm not
taking the ladder bro oh he's going
underneath wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait what are you gonna do wait Carl
what are you doing someone build me a
ladder please oh oh wait Chandler's Carl
wait jail is a time Otto stop time isn't
even going up anymore because he puts it
up so that Chandler what are you doing
no I've tried to film this and it didn't
work hey Jimmy I think we're getting the
car this time Carl thanks for the car
Jimmy you're the one that put me on this
team I like a get down mr. president
jumped in front of my shot and I've just
obliterated I demand a refund currently
your guys this time is two minutes and
five seconds while me and Chris is one
minute and 57 seconds yeah I like that
winning chris is going ah this is for
$10,000 Oh I'm bout to die wait let me
go over to you I haven't I have an idea
of meteors look I need you to kill them
as quick as possible okay I'm like free
hitting them yes one of you has to
finish this course in six seconds if you
guys want to win that $10,000 oh I love
doing this to Carl
yeah Chandler put all the pressure on
Carl what whoa oh you're gonna kill us
is that what you're gonna do oh oh no he
killed me no he's trying to kill me oh
okay here I go go go go go go go you can
do it Carl gotta go fast here I go go
girl I did it Carl
you lost by four seconds dad did I win
you my friend won $10,000 that you're
splitting in half of me yeah it wasn't
about me winning the money for my unborn
son it was more about taking the
opportunity from car thank you all for
coming out we'll see you at the next mr.
beast gaming video here's an inch screen
if there's not something there I don't
know Chandler's about to kill me all
right goodbye